bootle care podcast special guest in
here you might know her from uh Love and
Hip Hop which I have not watched in a
very long time I'm talking about like I
don't even know I think I might have
only watched the first season okay out
of Atlanta I think when it was like New
York Jim Jones was involved the first
season the OG's of it I think that's it
yeah and then I I don't know if I
stopped paying for cable or you're gonna
watch this one check check me out on it
uh Amy is here appreciate you Luciani
right yes Luciani that is a serious uh
gangster last name I have a pistol on me
right now and a chopper in the trunk
well we are in California where it's a
little bit more hairy in terms of the
legalities of such things this is not
Atlanta not Atlanta I'm definitely
loving it though how you liking Cali so
far so good so I'm ready to get outside
don't care like outside just the world
no I did that yesterday and the day
before I'm ready to a club scene vibe
I mean you live in Atlanta you ain't
gonna get nothing better than the strip
club there oh there's nothing like a
blue flame here it's just it's nothing
at all the nightlife here is very
disappointing
so what I'm gonna do after I'm done
working the next two days like when I
wanna you could go to like you know one
of these Hollywood clubs but they're
coming yeah no I don't wanna strip clubs
popping there's a place called uh Crazy
Girls it's cool
decent I don't want cool cab I'm
straight on that
yeah I mean you come from the epicenter
of
culture and strength yes so anywhere you
go here anywhere you go here you'll be
disappointed disappointed I'm I'm
disappointed because when I watch a lot
of the Instagrams and my friends who
live here they look like they're living
the club life but now that I'm here
texting them everybody's like [__] it
ain't nothing to do here there's clubs
but they're just not clubs I would go to
unless they're paying me
I like that yeah I like like if I'm not
getting paid I'm not going or if it's
like my friends got an album coming out
or something pop out maybe yeah it's got
to be like a friend got it a Killer Mike
had a thing the other night and that's
my boy so I came okay but it was at a
funeral home oh wow so la is just a
place you just pop out it's not staying
it's just in and out I'm not getting a
section staying for hours late I I just
opened the nightclub in Scottsdale
myself so for me it's like I'm like in
the industry so I'm not going out I'm
tired really I mean yeah I'm really
tired well I'm not from here and I'm
tired too but I want to go out no go to
Hollywood Boulevard did that already you
gotta oh I saw you by the way did you
shower before you came yes I did because
I was like what cause you were laying on
the street I did that was yesterday okay
I saw the pictures on your story and
it's a very very unsanitary sidewalk to
lay on I wanted to be a part of it I saw
Angela bass's name Martin Lawrence yes I
had to get very close to her somebody
might have died or bled or peed or
urinated it was three dots of blood
fornicated right on top of those Stars I
smelled it I think you're accurate yeah
no it's a Hollywood is what very wild
Place very uh it's so different I didn't
expect to see
it was just different I love it though
because I don't see it regularly did you
expect to smell so much human urine
um that was disappointing yeah
especially with me having larger
nostrils right
um You agreeing to write about the NASA
no I didn't
yeah it was just I don't know I like it
because it's different obviously in
Atlanta I'm around predominantly black
and a lot of hip-hop and a lot of it's
just it's a different smell so being
downtown I was like really let me blend
in here no jewelry on I just want to be
out here can anybody run up on you with
their CD yes of course somebody ran up
on me with a poem book
um just all type of strange things
happened that I enjoyed yeah so if
people don't know when you go to
Hollywood Boulevard there's a lot of
rappers who are not aware of the
technological advances in music anymore
and they still come up to you with a
straight face yes well this a burnt CD
and they expect you to give them your
money for it with the Sharpie marker
written and I'm like what am I supposed
to like I can't even play this in my car
then you got a CD player dude so
yeah well they at least trying they
trying to do they're trying trying to
come up with that question how long have
you been making music
I have been making music on and off I
would say
10 years a little less than 10 years
um the last year I actually started
taking it much more seriously I was
doing a lot more writing and doing the
behind the scenes and
that was more easier for me because
obviously as an independent artist
trying to push the music and put myself
out there it's a costly thing to do of
course very costly and I know you know
so I made a decision about a year and a
half ago I'm like you know what stop for
a second [__] get your business
together get your life together first
because I wanted it so bad but just
being out of order not having the income
and just not having the
the business plan for real for real
because me showing up and being pretty
and corrupt that [__] wasn't enough it's
not enough still to this day so took a
little break off really got more
organized and yeah this is the this is
the rebranch this is the comeback of The
Comeback Kid so give me uh because I'm
not like I said I don't watch Love and
Hip Hop I haven't watched Love and Hip
Hop for years like I said I have zero
clue right who's on Love and Hip Hop
Atlanta besides you
how did you get on the show what's going
on on the show what's the story lines
are you sleeping with anybody's men or
their fights have you pulled someone's
weave off yet is anybody getting [__]
up or reunion shows give me the recap
first no sleeping with these Menses okay
so like ew no it's a little scrappy on
there he is okay [__] shout out to him
see I know something yeah Scrappy is on
it um I can just say the ones who
they've released so far for the promo
that they released with myself on it so
for those people who know who've seen
the promo it's
um Erica Mena myself Erica Bank she's an
artist from Texas she's from Houston
from Houston she was dating finesse two
times yep so she and already newbies on
the show oh so this is your first year
this is my first year okay my first
season wow season 11 first one they
finally got a real rapper on it so Erica
Mena was like she was uh like Safari she
was on was she on the old school the New
York one yeah she moved to Atlanta she's
been here for some years now wow yep so
she was dating Safari and wow right
she was dating bow wow yeah she was
married to Bow Wow I think huh no I
think it might have been a marriage
no I didn't who was she who was she yeah
I know she dated Bow Wow you just
brought that back to my mind and then
she was dating the chick
she was dating the chick yep that was in
New York she was dating the chick jokes
ended up being Joe Budden's baby mama
you are right so she might have been
married to Bible you know some [__]
yeah it's it's crazy I was intertwined
on this show I I'm typically standing
there just looking at everybody like
left and right it's gonna be very
hilarious because it's like her love
history is like the scream tour meets
the Joe Budden podcast I like that sure
she and I just squashed our beef so I
was going to ad-lib and do some clowning
on her but I'm gonna try to keep it cute
we had a little small issue a couple
years ago they had to get addressed and
we are we're like 30 good now so 30 is
better than zero percent exactly so what
was the issue over
it was some petty I you know something
with some content
um I dropped a single and her team
reached out to the guy who did my
the image you know we found this nice
lovely big vault in Atlanta no artists
no one had shot there and then I found
it and heard people reached out and then
she reposted it the next week and of
course fans and supporters were in the
comments like Amy did it first Amy did
it first oh she like went and shot and
that's the exact same place the exact
same thing yeah so some petty girl [__]
but when the shade room reposted it I
commented on there and then she
attempted to change did you guys fight
no we didn't fight I gotta ask yeah I'm
just who knows rest in peace Jerry
Springer you know sometimes yeah you
gotta just duke it out yeah sometimes
you do but see I am honestly trying to
be on the show and not do that I've had
some situations but as I knew it would
come with it I'm not trying to scare the
money off I'm really on there for a a
bigger purpose to use the show like to
be a billboard cardi B was on it right
for sure and she made it it was supposed
to kicked the door down for people to be
like Ah that's a reality show chick
because yeah have cardi B's you know
cardi B cardi B cardi B I can't wait to
get mine yeah she definitely broke the
mold I think a lot of women get on the
show and the money is good and they
become complacent because it's like this
is a job I get paid for and there's no
larger goal so
um the show has reached out to me three
times in the last five years so you had
said no prior two times yeah so so what
made it right this time to
um they're gonna showcase my music and
focus more on I told them you got catty
[__] on the show that do their things
they're already getting paid more than
me let them stay in their position and
then you got the newcomers like me like
I'm focused on the music the show flew
out to Texas with me
um they come to my studio sessions they
come to my rehearsals like I want it to
be about the music and you know in the
beginning it was like no this kind of
works what we're doing here so we want
you to do this and I just first two
times like no I'm making decent enough
money already without this so this go
around
thankfully they are focusing more on
really who I am in the music and not
kind of making me try to date somebody
or hang out with the [__] I don't
know they're taking it back so I think
how it started and I'm glad that they're
doing that this year so that's why I'm
gonna come on I do I do feel like when I
walk like would see shows like that I'd
be like it feels like so many of these
beefs and relationships and [__] are
just like four storylines
you know it's crazy I thought the same
thing until now that I'm in it it's real
it's really real but how it happens
which makes it kind of turn and look
like is this real
sometimes the beefs are so old and so if
this if I had this argument big fall out
with you three weeks ago we know this
happened the whole cast knows it and
then a month later when it comes out me
and you might have squashed it so I'm at
your listening party and it's like [__]
y'all were just on the show fighting on
Monday but but the episode is old it's
old people don't really know how it it
works as far as the process of rolling
out so you see us out with the person
it's like I knew that was fake it's no
way y'all was really arguing like that
but
it was six weeks ago we filmed that you
didn't know that so it's a lot it's
definitely real you know you have some
who exaggerate it but it's definitely
real